let's go to Westminster should we we can
talk to the Foreign Secretary William
Hague good morning to you mr. Haig look
just
what's your reflection at this stage
we're the Conservative Party is as done
in all of this you've got a pretty
healthy share of the vote but obviously
you still a considerable number of MEP s
down here
well the governing party hasn't won
European elections for 30 years that
they've always been won in that time by
the Official Opposition usually by quite
a wide margin
so I think for us conservatives to only
go down about three percent from where
we were five years ago when we were in
opposition and only to be about one
percent behind labour in an election at
this stage it's a pretty creditable
result but of course you keep have won
the election we have to recognise that
and all across Europe who've seen some
pretty deep disillusionment and
disaffection with Europe so that message
has got to be heard loud and clear in
Brussels and coming to the general
election we have to be very clear in the
Conservative Party that if people want a
referendum on in or out of Europe they
get that by voting for a Conservative
government in the general election which
is very different from a European
election but you haven't got I mean we
all we hear from politicians all the
time that you know you're gonna be
listing you're going to be responding to
what the people have said in all of this
this seems to be a two-pronged attack
though people aren't happy with Europe
aren't happy with immigration and aren't
happy generally with the state of
politics in this country because this is
clearly as much as anything else a
pretty strong protest vote it is a
protest but I think you're right about
that and I think there is a lot of anger
and anxiety about those and other issues
so what are we going to do about that
well we are going to make sure we
provide the answers to those things and
get on with succeeding at what this
government has set out to do which
includes reducing immigration which
includes if we have a Conservative
government after next year's election a
referendum on Europe and of course most
importantly it includes a sustainable
economic recovery
with a long-term economic plan and that
you're not gonna get from a Labour
government so these are the things that
bring jobs that bring prosperity to this
country and these are the things we have
to make sure these are the answers we
have to be delivering over the coming
year a referendum on Europe yes and it's
clear people want that from the results
we've seen but but still you're holding
to your line I that you'd you'd hold a
referendum but you'd campaign to stay in
well what we say we'd hold a referendum
when we have set about fixing the
relationship between Britain and Europe
that means making Europe more flexible
more competitive having the ability to
bring powers back to the UK from the EU
and making it more accountable
particularly to national parliaments
then we would have a referendum and if
we succeed in achieving the things I've
just listed well then we would be saying
on this basis we can stay in the
European Union but the important thing
is the people would decide this is a
democracy there will be a referendum if
David Cameron is Prime Minister after
the general election and that's the main
thing for for people to bear in mind
when they vote in the general election
next year yet clearly one of the big
issues is not only immigration but you
know cross European migration that
cannot change can it whilst were in the
European Union that's that's surely not
going to be up for negotiation when you
you go to Europe should you win the next
general election there are things about
that that can change and that we are
changing for instance we're trying to
make sure that when people do come here
they're coming here for the right
reasons they are coming here for work
and to contribute to the economy and
that's why we've clamped down on benefit
rules bringing them into line actually
with many other European countries so
that people are not coming to the United
Kingdom to take advantage of our welfare
system that's part of the welfare reform
that is only taking place because there
was a change of government at the last
general election so there are things
that we can and are doing the Home
Secretary explained yesterday as you
know that we could do more in a
conservative only government in a
serve ative majority government that's
another reason we all set out to achieve
that next year